[Music]  this movement of entrepreneur got a lot  of people to become entrepreneurs who  should have never become entrepreneurs  right okay they just should have never  become entrepreneurs because  they did not experience the element of  being an entrepreneur an entrepreneur  thinks works is wired looks at money  people talent recruits sells  sells the dream everything an  entrepreneur does is identical to the  entrepreneur the only difference between  the entrepreneur and the entrepreneurs  the entrepreneur put up the money that's  it  meaning there is nothing else that's  different there the same amount of  sacrifices this guy's willing to make  this guy's willing to make he just  didn't put up the money